[Music]
well christian developing right now two
people have been found dead
inside the palms place near flamingo and
arville and a homicide investigation is
now underway
arko mana joining us now live with new
details here at six
orca
denise police believe that this was a
murder suicide and they say they found
two women dead inside a room here at the
palms place now
here at this hour there is still a
police presence here here's what we know
police say the two women who they
believe are locals did not check
out of their door was locked then
maintenance got into the room just
before 3 pm
and they found the women described as
black and in their 30's dead
police say both suffered from gunshot
wounds and something found inside the
room is giving a little more insight
into their relationship
from a note that was left in the room we
believe that they
are going to be at least somewhat
romantically involved but again i don't
have the specifics of that
police add that the two women appear to
have died within the last
12 hours no witnesses have come forward
yet
but they are canvassing the property to
see if anyone heard
any gunshots so of course stay with us
for updates and for more information as
we learn
more for now reporting live near the
palms orca mana 8 news now